well first of all thank you to the
organizers for I'm having us all out
here for such a fun meeting it's a great
topic and this talk is going to look
really different from what we saw this
morning in that my lab is really focused
on trying to understand the molecular
mechanisms that underlie enhancer
function and our approach to that
problem is to use quantitative data
coupled to computational models but I
wouldn't consider us a big data group
what you'll see are actually pretty
simple experiments but performed
quantitatively to try to interrogate
function and so what I wanted to start
with is actually this picture which is a
cartoon I'm sure you've seen many
versions of this kind of cartoon it's
the one that's still in undergraduate
biology textbooks about how enhancers
are which are these orange rectangles
bind to transcription factors which are
the red balls and recruit a bunch of
cofactors which allow them to loop up to
the promoter and touch polymerase and
the idea is that this sort of story of
protein-protein recruitment is how
enhancers work right so the regulatory
DNA serves as scaffold for recruiting
these proteins which recruit more
proteins and which loop up to the
promoter and this this story is really
anchored in a world view of gene
regulation from bacteria right which
tells us that we can understand gene
regulation from this perspective of
recruiting individual proteins to
promoter so a lot of the concepts that
we use through come from those initial
studies one of the things that's become
a sort of emerging hypothesis in
eukaryotic gene regulation and
especially mammalian gene regulation is
that we actually can't totally explain
gene regulation in higher organisms with
a simple modular view and one
complication is that it appears that
many regulatory elements such as
enhancers don't only contact the
promoter but they also contact each
other and this kind of insight comes
from high dimensional hi-c data and
things like this so this is a sort of
locust level extrapolation of that
hypothesis right
that the genome is a complicated
three-dimensional structure and that
this modular view of one regulatory
element contacting the promoter and
driving a particular expression pattern
might be an oversimplification and so
the the story that I want to tell you
about today is actually how we've been
thinking about this problem in the
context of a canonical gene in
drosophila development and how by
working on that gene we've got we got a
couple of different clues that led us to
think about questioning this bacterial
paradigm from a theoretical perspective
so sort of land on that at the end all
right so like I said we study this
problem in drosophila blastoderm embryos
this is a movie of drosophila
development using lattice light sheet
microscopy showing the early divisions
of the syncytial blastoderm so the fly
starts out as an embryo with a nucleus
in the middle it and that nucleus
divides a lot of times and without
selling cell membranes forming those
nuclei migrate out to the periphery of
the embryo until you get to this stage
called the blastoderm where those nuclei
are packed really close to the surface
and an enormous amount of transcription
takes place at this time one of the
reasons why we like the system is
because it's incredibly amenable to
quantitative experiments all the nuclei
are on the surface so we can use imaging
methods to precisely quantitate the
levels of transcription factors and
expression of their targets using
imaging that was the focus of my postdoc
work where I was really fortunate to
work with the Berkeley Drosophila
transcription network project which was
up on the hill and spearheaded by Mark
big and david knowles and mike aizen who
is my postdoc advisor so that project
really focused on using in situ
hybridization and floresta two-photon
confocal microscopy a couple of
fluorescent labeling of mrna and protein
to figure out how you could measure the
levels of transcription factors in their
targets and individual nuclei and the
entire drosophila blaster of embryo this
is a maximum projection image of a
stained embryo or nuclei are green and
two different genes are in blue and red
and then this is what happens to that
kind of data after it's been processed
into an image stack our from an image
stack into a point cloud which is a
computationally amenable representation
of expression data where we then get
around the problem of only having a
certain number of colors to stain jeans
for by staining embryos with the same
fiduciary marker so the same gene to
register all the embryos together and
then partnering it with a different gene
that we're querying and so we can use
that kind of basic labeling strategy to
develop three-dimensional atlases of
average gene expression for an arbitrary
number of genes where we have data for
you know approximately 50 to 100
different transcription factors and
targets in these six thousand cells on
the surface of the embryo and their
average position over about six
different time points so you can kind of
think of this sort of data as spatially
resolved microarray data for small
number of genes and but what I'm going
to show you for a lot of analyses today
are actually just line traces through
this kind of data because it's easier to
reason about which would look something
like this so if we're looking from the
anterior to the posterior of this embryo
you'll see a line trace where you see
expression we use a little trick where
we normalize our expression values to
the to a internal marker and that's what
this expression and the poles is and
that allows us to compare the absolute
expression level a relative expression
levels between lines so this might be an
enhancer that expresses in a particular
stripe and a mutant variant of that
enhancer that expresses to a lower level
and the average of the trace is this
dark line in the middle and then the
standard deviation is the gray shadow so
that's the kind of data will be looking
at all right so what I first want to do
is show you three experiments that made
us think that we should care about locus
level effects even in this canonical
developmental gene which is called even
skipped which is expressed in seven
stripes and the reason why I wanted to
show this data to this audience is that
I think this picture that I showed you
at the beginning of lots of enhancers
loop to the promoter is something that
people are getting more and more
comfortable with from things like hi-c
data but now we have a challenge which
is functionally what does it mean for
the expression of genes for lots of
things to be looped together and so I
think that you know these experiments
have sort of point to the fact that
even for these really well study genes
there are quantitative effects at the
locus level okay so what's the first
experiment that I'll show you this is an
experiment that's not usually done on
enhancers which is to replace them or
delete them with an intervening sequence
in large in a large piece so this was
actually done in a back and the
construct was made by Marty living Our
Mutual Ludwig and Marty Kreitman and
they very generously sent it to us so
that we could do quantitative imaging on
it and what this this is the even skip
locus these little gray boxes are the
enhancers there's one that drives
expression of stripes three and seven
one that drives expression of five or
six one in five and two the eve start to
enhance our usually lives here and they
replaced it with mini white ok so we
quantitatively stained this guy which
drives expression of Lexi and you can
see the wild-type traces here in blue
and these are all very precisely
controlled for time and then this is
what happens when you delete the stripe
to enhancer so definitely start to goes
down but notice stripe three also gets
messed up so does stripe seven and so
two straight six and so this is sort of
one of those first hints that if you're
if you were to think about the
experiment that people mostly do on
enhancers which is to take them out of
their endogenous context and hook them
up to a reporter and see that they drive
expression that completely misses the
the fact that it influences other
enhancers in the locus so that's that's
piece of evidence number one that we
should care about it piece of evidence
number two is an experiment that we did
for an entirely different reason which I
won't talk about and took us a long time
to interpret but I think actually is
interpreted in the context of this locus
level hypothesis so again this is on an
experiment on the even skipped enhancers
here we're going to think about the
enhancer that drives stripes three and
seven together and the enhancer the dr
stripes four and six together so those
are the pair of purple stripes and the
pair of green stripes and the experiment
is to simply take these two enhancers
and juxtapose them in different
orientations to one another okay and the
way that I'm going to show you data from
this is to just plot data from a single
cell in stripe for okay
so this in this in this stripe we know
that the expression is being driven at
least by the straight 46 enhancer right
and the question is what happens if the
37 enhancer is around right so if
everything is working totally modular
Lee it should not care right that
there's another enhancer there but it
does so if you stick the e 37 enhancer
behind the 46 enhancer the old
expression goes down I about to fold so
that's weird enough for the modular
hypothesis but if you move it to in
front of it it goes up okay so but the
answer here is that enhancers not only
care what else is around they care where
it is right so these locusts level
effects are important in that respect
and then this last bit of evidence that
i'm going to tell you is about a class
of enhancers that have been sort of
rediscovered in the last five years
actually based on a lot of functional
genomic data which I they've gotten
through a lot of different names
apparently redundant enhancers or
sibling enhancers or shadow enhancers
which mike levine coin which has been
the term that's really stuck in the
literature so these are enhancers that
drive expression in the same cells okay
so it's a say the single target gene is
controlled by the expression of multiple
enhancers and I'm not going to go
through the whole story of how we
uncovered one of these shadow enhancers
in the eve locus but suffice it to say
that the stripe to enhancer an extended
version of it and people known this for
a while actually was that this extended
version also drives a little bit of
stripe seven so there's a straight 37
enhancer and a striped 27 enhancer and
the experiment that allowed us to
understand something new about this pair
was that there's this really cool
misexpression experiment that Steve's
small developed which looks like this so
you take a transcription factor and you
hook it up to a different enhancer so
this is the transcription factor
Hunchback and what he's done is hook it
up to the snail enhancer which drives
expression along the belly of the embryo
where this transcription factor isn't
normally expressed and when you do that
and you look at Eve which is a target of
Hunchback you can see that the eve
stress
retract from hunchback and stripe seven
does this weird thing where it bulges ok
so again this story is published so i
won't go into any details but suffice it
to say that when you look at these two
different eve seven enhancers one of
them makes this blob in response to
hunchback expression and one of them
retreats ok so what this means is that
in the locust a single transcription
factor represses one and activates the
other so it's like driving with the
brakes on right and this is not unique
to Eve this is actually also true of
another pair of shadow enhancers for
krupal where there's one that dries
expression of a distal enhancer and one
that Rosie expression or proximal in the
drys they both drive the same pattern
that's why their shadow enhancers and
they exhibit this little loop of
hunchback by functionality as well and
they also respond to completely
different sets of activators ok so this
brought up an interesting question in
our mind which was if they're not just
redundant pieces of DNA right maybe
they're performing some interesting
circuit function in the embryo like
maybe there's something actually
important about the fact that they
respond to different regulators and we
wanted to think about and this is just a
picture of that idea right so now we
have this this sort of cartoon in our
heads of a couple of different enhancers
that bind to different transcription
factors and they're both impinging on
the promoter at the same time in the
same cells and we wanted to think about
what kind of experiment might be due to
test the role of these two different
enhancers in both patterning the embryo
and also understand how they might be
interacting at the promoter and I think
this is a pretty common experiment to
conceive of right which is that if we
have this situation we've got two
different enhancers and they bind to
different transcription factors what if
we measured the output of each one
separately and compared it to the output
of the piece with both of them in it ok
but then we realized that like basically
this could get so let's say we measure a
and we measure B what do we expect
we expect to see a and B a plus bead we
expect a times B to respect more than a
times B to expect the average and we
realize we didn't actually have a
rigorous null hypothesis for this at all
right and so we could do this experiment
but my graduate student was like I
wouldn't know how to interpret it we
could anything we find here I wouldn't
be able to tell you what it means so we
set about trying to think of a piece of
theory that we could do to help us
clarify this null hypothesis and what we
realized was that what we needed was a
piece of theory right so this sort of
this is something rob phillips likes to
call figure 1 computational biology or
figure 1 theory which is a piece of
theory to help us think of the right
experiment and i just like these quotes
about this in a way of thinking about
models in biology says models and
analytical pharmacology are not meant to
be descriptions pathetic descriptions of
nature they are designed to be accurate
descriptions with our pathetic thinking
about nature just substitute systems
biology for analytical pharmacology you
have it this was pulled out by a
colleague of mine in my department
Jeremy goon Lorna and rob phillips has a
much more compact version of this
statement which is models or logical
machines right so so our goal here is
not to build a model that's going to
reflect everything that we know about
transcription we want to build the
simplest possible model that's going to
help us reason about this system and I'm
priming you that way because this model
is very simple though so let's remember
what it was for all right so starting
again with this cartoon of two enhancers
interacting with promoter a and B this
if you think of these enhancers as
individual activating units right this
is formally identical to this problem
that people have considered a lot which
is two transcription factors in pinching
on the same promoter right these are
just two to potential activating units
and how they're going to act together to
control transcription and the dominant
framework for how people have considered
the transcription factor in product
transcription factor problem is in this
bacterial world view of protein
recruitment okay so
this is what people commonly refer to as
a thermodynamic formalism or
statistically their statistical
mechanical models what they basically do
is consider how transcription factors
bind to DNA how they can influence one
another's binding and how they influence
the binding of RNA polymerase okay and
here the transcription factors work by
decreasing the free energy of polymerase
binding to the promoter which is
considered to be the rate limiting step
for transcription okay so there's a huge
assumption in this model which is that
there is one effective rate of transfer
to one rate limiting step of
transcription okay and there are a lot
of really lovely reviews on this
formalism and it's been very powerful
and a lot of people have used it but
what we were struck by and trying to
think about this formalism for our
problem which was that one of the more
obvious hypotheses we wanted to consider
was what if the activators that bind to
these two different enhancers do
different things right what if they're
not what if they don't activate in the
same way and so we thought that this was
a pretty reasonable thing to consider
given that even in bacteria
transcription is a cycle and there are
transcription factors that are known to
act on different steps in the bacterial
transcription cycle and in eukaryotes
the transcription cycle is even more
complicated and recently people have
actually started to measure the
effective rates of the different steps
in these cycles and they found that
there are actually multiple rates that
are within range of one another so it's
not that there is one very slow step and
then a lot of very fast steps such that
you can ignore all the rest of them and
so what we wanted to do with this little
piece of theory was to consider the
following can we think about how
transcription factors act on a
multi-step cycle right and what kinds of
things could a framework like that
afford you and I think the kind of
diagram that I'm showing here basically
shows you that in the context of
spectrum of rates right if we have a
transcription factor acting on one of
those rates the overall rate of
transcription is still going to be an
effect of the other rates right so
you're not going to get a rate of
transcription that's just equivalent to
the transcription factor acting on a
single
okay so what can this kind of scheme
give you Oh actually so here's what's
underlying the model I don't think it's
important that we spend a lot of time on
this because the math is really simple I
just grabbed this actually literally out
of my graduate students notebook she has
amazing handwriting um which is that we
consider a simple cycle where there are
forward and reverse rates and you think
about the if you want to drive us or
closed form analytical solution to this
kind of cycle you can consider the
rejection rate which is basically how
many times you're going to co backwards
from a given node and the total sum of
transcription is going to be basically
the sum of all these effective rates so
this what this does is give you an
intuition for how the time you spend in
any given step is dependent on the rest
of the cycle and so a really nice
metaphor to think about is and this may
be because our collaborator al Sanchez
who's amazing was applying for
citizenship at the time he's like think
about a bureaucracy and how many times
you have to visit a given bureaucrat
depends on how mean all the downstream
bureaucrats are right so so then you see
one guy he's really permissive and you
go to the next step if he doesn't think
you filled out your form right you still
have to go back and see the first guy
reckon so it just gives you a sense that
like I showed you in that rate spectrum
diagram the overall time you're going to
spend any given step depends on what the
structure of the cycle looks like in
more detail you can also use a matrix
formalism based on stochastic chemical
kinetics that Al and Jana kanji have
developed back in two thousand eight
that allows you to basically do this for
any type of cycle with any kind of
internal loops that you want it's very
straightforward um we did this for an
incredibly simple cycle just composed of
two steps okay so that we can sort of go
through all these different logical
operations so I just don't want to whiz
through a couple of things that you
don't even need the mathematics for to
into it the first one is that using
kinetic control of the transcription
cycle you can produce all of the same
sort billion computations that you can
produce using combinatorial binding of
transcription factors to a piece of
regulatory DNA
as you as one has shown in the
thermodynamic formalism okay so Terry
hua did that originally I mean showed
that basically by different combinations
and binding you could make these
different boolean gates and you could
string them together to make all kinds
of interesting computations right and
that's nice because it makes you it lets
you think about how gene regulatory
networks might be wired together and you
can do exactly the same thing in a
kinetic formalism and here's just a
totally easy to understand example an
and gate right so let's say you have two
different rates one transcription factor
works on one and the other one works on
the other so if you only have one you're
still limited by the low rate of the
other but when you have both you can get
high transcription right and there we
elaborate in the paper which is on by
archive that you can enable all the
other gates too there's another example
having kinetic control of the
transcription cycle allows you to
integrate information over time right
now this is important because it allows
you to enable these computations without
the transcription factors having to be
there on the regulatory DNA at the same
time right so what you can do is
consider this is this a simple four step
cycle with some time delay in between
transcription factors arriving in the
nucleus such that you could distinguish
between the order of arrival right if
blue arrives before orange it doesn't
matter if you complete like the step
four if you haven't completed like step
one and nothing happens but if they
arrive in the right order things can
happen and there's actually a recent
paper from Mike Ella winces group that
showed that this is exactly the case for
two transcription factors that cycle in
and out of the nucleus in yeast and they
only work together to to positively
regulate transcription when they're out
of phase so it's it's a it's a formal
possibility that you could do things
this way all right so how about this
last thing which was the thing that we
wanted to do the actual piece of theory
for which is to think about the null
model of what would happen in our
experiment so first what I want to point
out is that in the context of the
recruitment model people have long
understood and shown that the null
expectation for how to activators should
work together
is that it should be multiplicative
right and this is because they work on
altering the free energy of polymerase
binding right so because both of the
free energy lives in the exponent so
both of them work on decreasing the free
energy of polymerase and that effect is
multiplicative okay in the context of a
kinetic model actually the null is that
if they're working completely
independently from one another they
should add together effects should add
together and so I'm just going to show
this kind of plot to distinguish between
those two null null hypotheses so that
we can consider further alternatives in
the next slide what this is basically
showing you is that the overall change
in the amount of transcription under the
recruitment model is multiplicative so
this is essentially the deviation from
multiplicative this is the change in
rate under a under the kinetic model I'm
so that this is the sort of deviation
from that additive expectation right so
you can see they're both falling along
their their lines yeah why is the
expectation additive in the kinetic
motors moral the expectation is additive
because you're considering two
transcription factors working on the
same step by completely independent
pathways call the same state it can work
yeah exactly so this is we're just
concerned so that we can compare the two
right we're gonna make the kinetic model
one-step just like the recruitment model
right and now we'll consider it with
multiple steps it's a great question
sorry I didn't clarify that all right so
now let's consider something with
multiple steps alright so if we have two
things working on the same step and we
randomized parameters for how effective
they are and working on that step what
we get is a distribution of values that
are basically additive to sub additive
right so if they both perfectly if they
act exactly the same way you're going to
get something additive if they have
slightly different effects it just makes
it sub additive if they work on
different steps you get this sort of
synergy that I talked about you get
something that's multiplicative almost
completely multiplicative and
so that's just that the yes the
deviation from multiplicative so the
reason why the annotation is different
here is because in order to compare the
kinetic framework to the thermodynamic
framework here you're this is indicates
the change in the fold change in
transcription output the total level of
transcription and this indicates the
change in rate right so what you have is
the change in basically the change in
rate if you had both of them there
versus the output if it's multiplied by
the measurement of one versus the other
yeah okay all right and then the last
the last possibility here is that you
have two transcription factors working
on two different step both working on
both different steps and then you get
this sort of smear over all of these
values so what this really points out is
that my graduate student was exactly
right which is that if we did this
experiment of measuring the output of
each one separately and then them
together we could not possibly interpret
what we would get out the other side
yeah so they under a thermodynamic
regime we might get something that looks
additive to said additive and that could
be a kinetic control could be
thermodynamic control but we could also
get these other things as well and so
instead what I think this little bit of
theory showed us is that we might want
to consider doing a completely different
kind of experiment which is that instead
of measuring each thing separately and
then together we should consider a
duplication right so in this case we
have two enhancers we duplicate them and
if they work on the same steps which
they should because they're duplicates
of one another they're both get
influenced the same step and having more
of them isn't going to help us but if we
have some sequence change in the second
enhancer such that it behaves
differently and regulates this a
different step two more extent or a
different stuff all together we should
get some synergy between them right and
it turned out that we'd actually done an
experiment like that many years ago but
we didn't really know how to think about
it which was this is the eve stripe to
enhancer one copy of it and two copies
of it and you get absolutely no boost in
transcription but if you add a bunch of
binding sites for a regulator that
doesn't have a lot of binding sites in
the East ripe to answer you can jack up
transcription quite a lot
so this is just to say that I think it's
consistent with the idea of a kinetic
model here and it's just an alternative
for us to begin to consider and in the
context of this meeting I think there
are a couple of interesting points for
us all to think about the first one is
and maybe this is just interesting for
me to think about they're a bunch of
experiments that we've figured out to
really test for the presence of kinetics
energy and whether or not it's a thing
in a much broader sense I think it's
important for us to consider
alternatives to this very prevalent
equilibrium framework and what kind of
constraints are there in the equilibrium
framework versus the kinetic framework
so what sorts of things can a kinetic
framework by you that may be a
thermodynamic one cannot and vice versa
and I think this is especially
interesting in terms of evolution which
is I would love to talk to people about
more the other really big challenge here
right this is a very simple model based
on effective rates which is how do we
link rates to molecules right so what's
actually happening in terms of binding
on regulatory DNA and other cofactors
that might be there and we've done some
work on that to which I would also be
happy to talk to people about and then
finally I'm in the grander scheme of
things if we now have to consider gene
regulation not just at the level of
single enhancers but multiple enhancers
which are binding to different TFS how
much of an approximation is the modular
view of enhancer function and if it is
an approximation in what cases is it and
so fractionally how much should we care
about it and I think that that's
important for us to consider as well
thank you to my crazy lab who are here
featured in animal hats many of the
people you can't really see Clarissa
because she's eating Ben's face but this
is clarissa this has been this is evil
Wonderlic who did all the work on the
crew prepare krupal shadow enhancers and
also max taller hero both moved on and
because I couldn't resist this as our
current lab photo from this year there
was an exhibit of the Dutch masters at
the MFA these are paper doilies but
they're a wonderful group to work with
and it's truly a pleasure and thank you
for your attention
the last night when you said very little
evidence for medics energy you meant
evidence for the a plus B what I
specifically mean is experiment actually
demonstrated in light of the three
panels that you've drawn ah yes okay so
the three panels that I drawn is I don't
think that that experiment measuring a
measuring the measuring a plus B can
actually distinguish between these
models either thermo dynamic or kinetic
models I think that's what our piece of
theory showed us it sort of pointed us
to qualitatively different kinds of
experiments and the kinds of experiments
that we're doing our to take an array of
transcription factor binding sites right
and saturate it and then at saturation
add binding sites for a different
transcription factor to see if we can
boost expression further right so that's
outside the thermodynamic regime right
because once your saturated you should
be so you prevented the thermodynamics
model must predict an activation synergy
you do multiple due to multiple bounce
activators acting together and that is
cut the kinetic model you know would not
recruiting that that's energy by default
because it there are separate steps no I
think well I think the way I would I
would summarize it in those terms is
that what you want out of your null
hypothesis right is to tell you whether
something beyond independent action is
happening right so like it and that in a
thermodynamic framework what you would
expect by from independent action of two
elements be they transcription factors
or enhancers is multiplicative output
right
you can have you can have constraints on
that model district which prohibit
independent action within the time of
damage framework and then you'll get the
same but show exactly but without
independent so that tells you if you saw
that you would say ah they don't act
independently right it requires some
differ it requires some interaction in
the system such that they don't act
independently and so that would be
interesting to follow up I think the
problem is that because the null models
of independent action themselves can
give you such a variety of behaviors
depending on whether or not you assume
it's a thermo dynamic or kinetic view
like I couldn't tell you whether or not
something sort of interesting beyond
Independence was happening in those
experiments does that help okay yeah him
oh sorry all right well you just open
this you know let's say whole two could
be recruited indirectly fear factor a or
effector be right then in the context of
just the equilibrium model you could
still have a nativity of the
contribution of a and B to bind me say
again well if you have a you know factor
anybody to blindside a cookie Paul to
write this is like an April to
interaction and protein we could buy
it's a side B but also interact with
fall to the right so then the
probability of popular we could and love
got the treasures of those proteins it's
just the sum up there after two so I'm
not sure that it's necessarily kinetic
buted you know again a nativity think
you're gonna have a nativity at least he
knows I they're definitely I mean
there's a huge model uniqueness problem
here right which is that if I see
multiplicative click activity or I see
additivity there are ways of wrangling
the underlying model such that you could
explain it with one or the other yeah
don't map absolutely absolutely and
undoubtedly they're both playing a role
right if kinetics energy is a thing at
all right it's it's not that cooperative
binding or sort of equilibrium view is
completely irrelevant for gene
regulations these these things are not
mutually exclusive I think part of my
goal in presenting this was to just
think about another world
oh that might be important for
rationalizing about gene regulation
especially in light of the fact that we
think so much about transcription
factors and how they bind to DNA
especially in terms of their equilibrium
properties but know much less about
their how they affect specific steps in
transcription and that's because
structurally they're very hard to deal
with right so I think that that's a if
you if you had an ideal data set for
thinking about kinetics energy it would
be the sort of classification by my
function on transcription which we
really don't have or very many things
equilibrium or can practically value any
situation but what they cannot go you
cannot resolve you the kinetic
experimental show and I think this kind
of experiments in that are not going
rule out equilibrium model because if
you see a temporal response that's
something about the glue
no this one was not modelo its
experiment yeah the other place that I
think it's gonna be really there will be
there will be big differences is
actually in thinking about how you can
move in evolutionary time from one
regulatory strategy to another in the
sense that in the kinetic regime you
have the operator neutral space is is
different right in that you can add
factors that affect rates that are not
wouldn't affect your overall
transcription rate so you have a
different sort of buffering scheme and
we're starting to think about that that
now right so is there a way in which a
kinetic regime is more amenable to
exploring the sort of fitness landscape
in a smooth way if you want to move
between one regulatory strategy and
another and I suspect that there is
agree with you that the kinetic
experiments are one distinguishing
regime and I think actually the
evolutionary plasticity might be another
regime
even kinetic experiment may not cover
was always really can imagine an
equilibrium faculty be impressive does
it there imagine they are acting on the
only glimmer a sealable TV I say yes is
it the fact that once you show you can
implement any kind of logic gates and
string it together you could implement
these functions right to me the only way
you can tell it apart is quite different
i manage yes I agree I mean I I'm glad
that people are are I wonder I i guess i
would i guess i would point out again
that i don't know that proving that it's
one way or the other is the is the
mindset that I would go into these
experiments with I think that because
they're not mutually exclusive I think
it's just it's a regulatory regime that
may also play a role right and the and
there is I think a very deep problem of
model uniqueness as dynamic measurements
get better and better it may be that
it's more person Onias to explain a lot
of that stuff in a kinetic regime that
it is in a thermodynamic regime
implement and a logic gate but
nevertheless if you'll assume that the
particles sits a factor will have at the
same role in independent partner whether
using a looking else experiment that
involves a lot of pairs of social
factors and others assumption that east
a special factors have always the same
role in the logic gate cannot
distinguish them others
you mean experimentally if you were just
to try empirically define them based on
classes possible factor looks at like
100 of pairs of them yeah repeating made
up mascots on factors I don't think that
should i think the other reason why this
this model is interesting to me is that
it it doesn't exclude the fact that
transcription factors can have context
dependent function and in fact it
doesn't even require that transcription
factors act exclusively on one step they
can act on multiple steps they just have
to act on multiple steps in slightly
different ways right you get the same
combinatorial logic out of two
transcription factors that both work on
steps one two and three as long as they
do it to different extents right and so
I think it's it it's not it's not too
hard to imagine those context those
parameters changing in a
context-dependent way I think the other
thing that thinking about things in this
way again just sort of makes makes one
think about different kinds of
experiments that you might do is it
casts the promoter in a very active role
in terms of setting the spectrum of
effective rates that enhancers have to
work on right so that's another sort of
category of experiment that you might
imagine is to take a given enhancer and
test it against multiple different
promoters or to even take a given set of
a given set of promoters and test for
the sort of spectrum of effective rates
that they that they exhibit and so again
I think it just sort of spurs you to
think about the problem in a slightly
differently about what you have in mind
with what are these kinetic steps along
the cycle because I mean the more I'm
thinking about it in my mind right I can
also say any kind of state the promoter
can take on any combination of what
factors about to what sides yeah is it
different states and the promoter is
moving between these states in a
stochastic manner by grabbing an
individual factors and that rates can be
depending on what the current state is
in a complicated way right sure yeah
that starts looking very very much like
your model right right so I think that I
don't know what what well yes
we have actually mind when you think of
you still so it's important to remember
that the model is effective rates right
so these are things that are bundled
together into effective rates they do
not have to be specific molecular states
right and so in that in that sense I
think you can abstract out the molecular
details it's those those plots of
spectrums of rates that I showed you
from Jeff jealous is allowed in the
context of promoters difference between
an avenue kinetic that it just all the
colors you say I disagree because in
this armor there's also kinetics in
binding and unbinding of transcription
factors even within a thermodynamic
model right I think the key question
though is that the the fundamental
assumption of the thermodynamic
framework is that there is a single rate
limiting step that everything gets piped
through right all activators act in the
same way because there is one step where
ATP gets burned and that introduces
irreversibility in the model which is no
longer in equilibrium right yes so if
you want to say that there are several
steps in which ATP is burned and it's
irreversible then I like to know what
you have your mind I think there are a
lot of different steps where ATP gets
burned and eukaryotic transcription
right I think you know tell me a couple
about nucleus own modification or
remodeling how about post translational
modification of transcription factors
Universal open up his glories leaves a
new one comes amiss
ctd modification yeah but I mean I think
it speaks to this sort of deep question
about epigenomics and and or you know in
its or nucleosomes and their role in
gene regulation are they permissive such
that they're out of the way and then we
can think about gene regulation
happening at equilibrium or do they play
an information-processing role in
interpreting transcription factor
binding such that there is some active
competition between transcription
factors and nucleosomes where ATP is
burned and it is an out of equilibrium
system right I think that that's fully
possible even though accessibility
measurements tell us that these regions
are free of nucleosomes those those
assays are largely done at very high
concentrations of DNA straightly there
are mobile nucleosomes in lots of active
enhancer elements and so equilibrium
context like Lucas unmediated cover
tivity absolutely absolutely you don't
necessarily doesn't necessarily have to
be out of equilibrium in order to have
nucleus own competition but it does it
does change the way that you might think
about the relationship of affinity to
function of transcription factors if
it's an out of equilibrium process right
such that you know broadly speaking is
it more important that your
transcription factor is bound there for
a long time or is it more important that
it like touches the DNA many times I
don't think we have a good in sense of
which one of those regimes is true I
also think that there's you know the the
possibility that a kinetic regime might
more easily reconcile with the strong
functional role of many weak sites over
you know a few very strong sites so I've
definitely gone way over my time I real
good but I know I'm very pleased I'm and
I'm very happy to talk about all of
these things all of these things more at
length thank you all for your questions
you